nous allons maintenant procéder au vote
les résultats s'affichent et la couleur
verte domine largement le tableau
le projet de résolution aels 5 est
adoptée
sur les 183 pays représentés à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
143 condames l'annexion des territoires
Ukrainiens par Moscou
je viens d'assister à un moment
important peut-être même historique
un peu avant le vote l'ambassadeur russe
aux Nations Unies a dénoncé un plan
occidental en Ukraine qui viserait à
affaiblir la Russie
l'Ukraine a été choisi par ce groupe de
pays dans ce but ils en ont pris le
contrôle
et s'en servent de plateforme pour
tester les armes de l'OTAN et pour
combattre la Russie en utilisant un
autre peuple c'est-à-dire les Ukrainiens
jusqu'au dernier
en plus de 7 mois de guerre les lignes
n'ont pas bougé en mars 141 pays avec
condamné l'agression russe en Ukraine 5
avaient voté contre dont la Russie est
35 s'étaient abstenu dont la Chine ce 12
octobre le résultat est quasi identique
avec un même niveau d'abstention encore
abstentionniste d'enfants de nouveaux
partis des puissances comme la Chine le
Pakistan ou encore l'Inde
monsieur le Président mon premier
ministre l'a dit sans équivoque cela ne
peut pas être une aire de guerre avec
cela en tête c'est à dire le combat pour
une solution pacifique à travers le
dialogue et la diplomatie l'Inde a
décidé de s'abstenir
cette résolution n'a pas de valeur
contraignante au-delà de la condamnation
elle appelle à ce qu'aucun État ne
reconnaissent les territoires ukrainiens